come on
so if Taylor was running it and I go
here that is young versus young that's
the class right you understand he's
coming he's running at me now and I hit
him from here that is still young versus
young to get it okay and that would be a
clash that's not a young reconciliation
and it's not Aikido and we have to
figure out it's like a physical puzzle
we have to figure out how do I in
January a backwards fall right without
it being generated by the obvious okay
the best way of thinking about this is
kokujo is the kind of cut a gash on the
head okay
so go to the - he comes in and you kind
of round this corner and he's actually
going forward his energy was coming this
way and then it made a circle do you see
it's still going forward even though
it's now oriented in that same direction
you get it it's supposed to here and I
okay so we have to figure out how to hit
cook you home to not be a clash and
there's going to be some clues so
anytime I confronted him right this is
almost always going to be a
/ so if I go here and I go like this if
you look at my angle I'm in front of him
you see it looks like it works everybody
is trying to go backwards but bigger
boom hits you because gamma versus Young
who has the most force at impact who has
the most masks who's got the most
acceleration that's we would override
that energy do you guys get that okay so
what we're going to do is not be in
front of him but move behind him this
technique I'm behind you see not here in
front I did you front then you belong
like that
by the way I'm back here back behind
them you guys see them so if you take
[Music]
one I go behind this energy and then the
10-count would be here of trying on him
well I wouldn't need that foot but I
need that hip so one I bring my other
foot side by side side by side okay what
behind
oh whoa behind behind his head behind
his head
side by side okay right under your feet
mid-foot vector got it not here on here
not he'll wait side by side
pull the hip all the way out straight
hips okay let's try that far
we're not enter I'm at this back corner
you see that this is a fighting area
where you always want to be so it'll go
awesome
it's too far just right into that corner
right here now like this you see and I'm
not a tightrope and he leans on me and
so your case
Cordia Brown don't lean on me and all
this kind of crap okay and choreography
is he'll crazy he'll do that that's not
right I give so when I get to this back
corner this pad goes here you see in his
head is now on my upper arm I do it one
two this is me this is me starting to
turn it around what
- and I know like this why to bring it
in boom
not with your elbow
why
you
okay try not out you the technique is
going in in okay not saying out in and
this is going to come in
here ship his grip under my Center not
my hat his grip
one side I have to use Ikey the
technique doesn't work I can't I don't
go like this okay I give them back to
space okay so I'm not I have just that
perfect amount of friction this is the
hard part but if I keep trying to only
the other thing I will not get the
technique okay so because you are not
doing that you are trying to throw his
arm so you that's why you're trying to
hit his arms okay but I want his head
his head is what I want you see that so
there's connection down here so you can
let go this is the connection that I
want okay
so that's the drill one two there then
he lets go then I keep this going
one two and then he let go and I have to
move his head my energy goes up up not
like this you see that in body boom boom
one to drill body you see one - he lets
go body
[Music]
then wrists and my spine not have no
wrist wrist wrist okay then let's watch
his body so he came in and he's gonna
give it on that foot do not do not let
him walk around like this it's no
different then you give me noggin I have
to give it him right on that foot you
see off my foot do you understand what
you can get a downside
he's very strong all that put one so his
head is not going forward with my heart
will settle his head's going back
you see I have not clashed so his head
is going back his head for not and I
stay with it
I'm going the same direction his head
too
don't let it go stay with it this way is
my projecting don't fall onto this
this rotate no there's no rotation no
running
twist the tissues don't free of my rope
boom
Oh
not independent okay
we're gonna this is beginning what
you've been doing is beginner them
beginner ok beginner right here boom
take his face out so you can't raise up
and I can't fall on that foot that's
what has to be ground and he has to be
like he can't be leaning okay I just
take his weight off
[Music]